When I recently found out that my husband's
favourite pie is lemon meringue,
I knew that I had to make him one.
With only a few lemons left on my tree,
I got to work immediately.
I started by making a crust using an all purpose
eincorn flour that's bursting with nutrients and flavor
since it hasn't been stripped to stay soft stable.
There's just nothing like a flaky,
buttery crust.
Which is why I won't be using a freshly milled
100% whole grain ironcorn for this one.
I got two Crestwell Freeze
one for another pie.
My chickens are laying eggs again
and you're not going to believe
how orange the yolks are.
Which comes my commitment to raise them on fresh pasta
aka new backyard grass daily.
I don't use cornstarch in my kitchen.
Instead, the all purpose ironcorn
thickened up the lemon custard perfectly.
After tempering the egg yolks with the lemon custard,
I finished my pie crust by baking it with a
layer of Parchment foil
and beans to keep from collapsing during the pre bake.
The last step was to make my merengue,
which was really fun to do
and I'm actually a new fan of meringue.
This entire pie was very
lightly sweetened with maple sugar
and all of the ingredients are nutrient dense,
mostly from my land.
So when my husband took a bite
his first words were oh my gosh,
this is the best one yet, honey!